I'd have to say you seem ballsy enough
to me to pretend to be a cop
well you'll be disappointed to know I
jumped out a window
oh I'm sad I got that wrong
hi I'm Charlize Theron I'm Michelle
Rodriguez hi I'm Brie Larson and you
guys are watching unilad nope nope
I'm Bree and this is
Oscar winner and this is do you even
know me by unilad okay who's going first
I'll go first okay uh what's my greatest
dislike chewing loudly
fennel British people
oh my God It's gotta be the chewing
Lolly is really affecting her chewing
loudly yeah we gotta test it out
I'm gonna try us out of dinner
chewing loudly
chewing lonely oh the same yeah I said
that like five minutes ago
no way you really really know me
never talk about hating fennel I hate
fennel wow okay learning something new
every day okay which rapper almost threw
up when I took them
skydiving what
cardi B post Malone
Snoop Dogg
one of them you're my hero you know
what is that word
so did you take any of these yeah yeah I
was like wait a minute I don't think
I've ever gone skydiving with any of
these people I'd remember something like
that
um yeah which rapper almost threw up
when I took them uh stunt driving I
don't think it's cardi I think it's
Snoop yeah it's either snowboard post I
want to go Snoop too
wow you were in a car with her
wow yeah she's pretty bad wow your
life's cool no I love her how did I
avoid the police at a house party when I
was 18. a pretended I was only here
delivering pizza B pretended I was also
a police officer but undercover C jumped
out the window and ran away into the
snow
I think it's uh it's uh the first one a
hmm I'd have to say you seem ballsy
enough to me to pretend to be a cop
well you'll be disappointed to know I
jumped out a window
which of these trades do I have uh I am
an eager beaver I am
I am a cheapskate
um
which one is it which one are you yeah I
feel like you could be a neat freak yeah
I could Pinter as a neat too
yeah she looks like she cares about the
details you know
I'm sorry
oh yeah what's my star sign is it Taurus
Gemini or cancer cancer what what's my
star sign I don't know that
Gemini Taurus cancer
no you're Gemini you're Gemini that
could be a gemini or cancer or a dress I
don't know what any of it means
apparently I'm schizophrenic ladies and
gentlemen I feel like we talked about
the Gemini thing your Gemini I think we
talked about it but maybe is cancer the
lion
I don't remember my mom's a Gemini what
are you yeah I'm a cancer
I got a little lion in me too
I got a line yeah that makes sense okay
what was I allergic to on the set of
Captain Marvel a Samuel L Jackson's
smoked salmon breakfast rolls B my tabby
cat co-star see my latex suit
latex a lot of people are allergic to
latex you know a burning man you figure
this out quick or when you have surgery
yeah I feel like I'm happy that cats
it's a very common thing that people are
allergic to cats I love that cat by the
way yeah yeah Mona Lisa my terrible
liars I'm just trying to think
it's that it's literally it's the cat
latex it's the cat
s are made out of latex are they um
[Music]
someone has experience Eon Flex anymore
whoa all right I'm doing this for my
next one okay what color is my eyes
there's like a million colors that's
silly dude you're famous for your eyes
they're not blue it's not Frank Sinatra
what are they are you like really yeah
blue dude no but there's more colors
that's why I feel like we were supposed
to get there's multiple choice because
there's something that I don't know she
doesn't have different color eyes no no
no she doesn't have different color eyes
Hazel I avoid the um
blue and brown what is yours I'd say
blue gray blue green
well closer to the pupil but like
ah dude come on
people avoid the eyes
yeah I want to avoid that yeah uh what
did I recently uh grow
um
this could be good
it's very broad okay so what did you
grow what did I recently grow especially
for a roll this is not helping toenails
what armpit hair armpit hair or mono
brow yeah armpit hair armpit hair mono
brow really
come on guys you gotta like yeah I was
very proud about my armpit hair so I'm
not surprised you guys no because we all
were like
who was my first celebrity autograph
from a meatloaf B Madonna C Princess
Diana
whoa you're good at this game
she's not old enough for a Princess
Diana
autographs like like yeah but sometimes
you know they could be at an event
randomly and then you're there no
Meatloaf I mean you could probably see
him in an Austin party she seems like
the type to go yeah
[Applause]
the third who's Madonna Princess Diana
it's Madonna Madonna Madonna it's
meatloaf
that's so bad you guys we really don't
know you should know
I had the beanie baby he won
thank you so much I think someone's
pissed off about that win okay thank you
for watching yeah but I am pissed off
thanks guys chronic 2001.
shoot me you here
oh my God The Chronic